hi there today we're going to look at
end to end object detection with
transformers by Nicolas carrion
Francisco masa and others at Facebook AI
research so on a high level this paper
does object detection in images using
first a CNN and then a transformer to
detect objects and it does so via a
bipartite matching training objective
and this leaves you basically with an
architecture that is super super simple
compared to the previous architectures
that had all kinds of engineering
hurdles and thresholds and hyper
parameters so really excited for this as
always if you like content like this
consider leaving a like comment or
subscribe let's get into it so let's say
you have a picture like this here and
you're supposed to detect all the
objects in it and also where they are
and what they are this task is called
object detection so a good classifier
here would say there's a bird right here
and so this is a bird and then this here
is also a bird right they can be
overlapping these bounding boxes so this
is you see the first problem that bird
why is that green nevermind okay and
those are the only two objects so
there's a number of very difficult
things here first of all you need to
sort of detect the objects you need to
know how many there are
it's all it's not always the same in
each image there can be multiple objects
of the same class there can be multiple
objects of different classes they can be
anywhere of any size that can be
overlapping in the background small or
across the entire image they can include
each other partially so the problem is a
very very difficult problem and previous
work has has done a lot of engineering
on this like building detectors and then
kind of you want to classify every
single pixel here and then you you you
get like two detection right here that
are very close for the same classes they
are that must maybe be the same instance
right so there's only one thing here and
not
things and so on so there there used to
be very complicated architectures that
solve these problems and this paper here
comes up with a super simple
architecture and we'll kind of go from
the high level to the low to the
implementation of each of the parts so
what does this paper propose how do we
solve a task like this first of all we
put the image and the image here without
the labels of course we put it through a
convolutional neural network encoder
since this is an image task it's you
know kind of understandable that we do
this mostly because CNN's just works so
well for images so this gives us this
set of image features and I think this
this vector here is not really
representative of what's happening so
let's actually take this picture right
here and throw it in kind of an angled
way and what what we'll do with the CNN
is we'll simply sort of scale it down
but have it multiple so here it's three
channels right it's red green and blue
like this three channels but we'll scale
it down but we make it more channels so
yeah so more channels okay
but it's still sort of an image right
here it still has the image form okay so
the the CNN basically gives us this
thing which which is sort of a higher
level representation of the image with
many more feature channels but still
kind of information where in the image
those features are and this is going to
be important in a second because now
this thing which is this set of image
features goes into a transformer encoder
decoder and this is sort of the magic
thing here as as a component we'll look
into that in this in a second but we'll
take it out right here is this set of
box predictions so outcomes each of
these boxes here is going to be
consisting of a tuple and the tuple is
going to be the class and the bounding
box okay
so an example for this could be bird
bird at x equals two y equals five okay
that that's an example another example
of this could also be there is nothing
at x equals seven y equals nine okay so
nothing the nothing class is a valid
class right here and that's also
important but safe to say there is this
set of box predictions and then that is
basically your output right these things
are your output if you have those things
you can draw these bounding boxes you
can assign the labels the question is
how do you train it now what you're
given is a database of images and these
images as you see here on the right
these images already have by human
annotators drawn these bounding boxes in
and also labels so this here would be
annotated with bird and this here would
be annotated with bird but it doesn't
have any of these like it doesn't
annotate the nothing classes or and so
on so the question is how do you compare
the two can you simply say okay if the
first one here is the bird and then and
the second one is this bird then it's
good but then you know that the ordering
shouldn't matter you simply simply care
whether you have the correct bounding
boxes you don't care whether you have
put them in the correct order and also
what if your classifier does something
like this it outputs those two boxes we
see here but it also outputs this here
and says bird or like one that is
slightly off and says bird and so on so
how do you deal with all of these cases
so the way that this paper deals with
all of these cases is with their
bipartite matching loss this thing right
here so how does it work let's say your
where can we go let's say your
classifier so here is an image I'll have
to wait for this to catch up here is an
image and we put it
through this entire pipeline and we get
a set of predictions right and they're
going to be class bounding box class
bounding box class bounding box now the
first thing you need to know is that
there are always the same amount of
predictions right there are always this
size here is fixed that's large n okay
that is sort of that's kind of a maximum
of predictions since you can always
predict either a class or the nothing
class in in this case you could predict
anywhere from zero to five objects in
the scene right okay and then the second
thing is from your from your database
you get out an image with its bounding
box annotations right that are made by
human laborers let's say these two and
you also do class bounding box class
bounding box but now you see we only
have two two instances so here we just
pad with the nothing class so I don't
know what the bounding box should be for
the nothing class it doesn't really
matter nothing
no bounding box nothing no bounding box
no bounding box so your ground truth
labels if you will are also of size n so
you always compare n things here on the
left that your classifier output with n
things on the right now as we already
said the question is how do you deal
with you can't simply compare one by one
because the the ordering should not be
important but also you don't want to
encourage your classifier to always kind
of if there is if if the one bird is
very prominent right you don't want to
encourage your classifier to say do you
say that here's a bird here's a bird
there's a bird right here hey hey
there's a bird there's a bird there's a
bird and basically just because the
signal for that bird is stronger and
basically ignore the other bird what you
want to do is you want to encourage some
sort of your classifier to detect if it
has already detected an object it
shouldn't detect
again in a slightly different place so
what the way you do this is with this
bipartite matching loss so at the time
when you compute the loss you go here
and you compute what's called a maximum
matching now what you have to provide is
a loss function so we can there's a loss
function L and L will take two of these
things L will take the read the
predicted thing of your model and L will
take the true under one of the true
underlying things and L will compute a
number and we'll say how well do these
two agree so you can say for example if
either of them is the nothing class then
I have no loss like I don't care about
them that gives you no loss but if the
two if the two classes agree and the two
bounding boxes agree then it's very good
right and we maybe even gives like some
negative loss or give loss zero but if
if the bounding boxes agree but the
classes don't agree then you say that's
bad or the other way around if the
classes agree in the bottom or even if
everything disagrees it's the worst what
what you're basically saying is if if
these two would correspond to each other
right if the thing on the left were the
prediction for the thing on right which
we don't know right it could be that the
thing on the right refers to the bird on
the right and the thing on the Left
refers to the bird on the left so would
be natural that the bounding boxes
aren't the same but you say if these
were corresponding to each other what
what would the loss be how well would
they do and now if you compute this
bipartite matching what you want I guess
it's a it's a minimum matching in this
case what you want is you four to find
an assignment of things on the left two
things on the right a one to one
assignment this is an example of a one
to one assignment everything on the left
is assigned exactly one thing on the
right such that the total loss is
minimized right so you're going to say
I'm going to align the things on the
left with the things on the right such
that it's maximally favorable right I
give you the maximum benefit of the
doubt by aligning these things and what
so in the best possible case what's the
loss okay
hope this is this is somehow clear so
this you're trying to find the
assignment from the left to the right
that makes that basically is the best
case for this output right here where
you really say oh okay here you output
the output a bird very close to the bird
ear in the ground truth label that's
this here so I'm going to connect I'm
going to connect these two because
that's sort of it's it's it gives the
model the most benefit of the doubt and
the loss that you have at the end of
that matching so this loss here would
only then count wherever these
connections are that loss is going to be
your training loss okay so this solves
the problems we had before it is not
dependent on the order because if you
reorder the things your minimum matching
will simplify it will simply swap with
it it is it is um if you output the same
bird multiple times only one of these is
going to be assigned so if if this here
is that bird only one of them only this
one maybe is going to be assigned to
that one and the other ones can't be
assigned to that one are forced to be
assigned to a different one let's say
this one here and are going to incur a
loss so you encourage your model to
output let's say diverse bounding boxes
different bounding boxes for things okay
so this D solves these problems and it's
very clever and there are algorithms to
compute these these minimum matchings
and they use the Hungarian algorithm
which will give you exactly such a
matching again this is possible because
you have n things on each side and the N
is in effect
here is a the maximum of objects that
you can detect at once I guess if there
is less you can simply pad right here
and then the model of course is
encouraged to come up with the equal
number of no class predictions because
if it outputs a prediction when it
shouldn't right if it already predicts
two things and these are assigned to
these two things and then it outputs one
more thing it is going to be penalized
because it should output three things
with no class but it has output
one-to-many with a with a class is going
to be penalized okay so the this is a
pretty pretty cool thing it again it
relies on the fact that you have n on
both sides but you can make n so large
that basically it covers all of the
cases so you can make n like 50 so you
can detect up to 50 things in a scene
alright that's the algorithm in a
high-level they do show their loss here
you see the loss ultimately is going to
be so it's going to be over this
matching right here that's the minimum
bipartite assignment that basically
minimizes this total loss over your
prediction and label matchings and the
loss they come up with here I said you
have to give the algorithm a loss is
this one and they kind of go into how
they do it I don't think it's super
important so the the class algorithm
sorry the loss on the class labels I
think it's going to be a soft Max or a
sorry a cross-entropy loss like in usual
classification and the loss on the to
say whether to bounding boxes agree is a
mixture of the l1 loss that compares to
bounding boxes and this iou loss which
is not dependent on the scale of the
bounding boxes it kind of computes how
much fraction of the two bounding boxes
overlap but in any case the lost base
they consist of saying how eyeli how
much do the labels agree and how much do
the bounding boxes agree okay again this
is only possible because after that you
compute this matching otherwise you
would have no clue which boxes to come
which predictions to compare to which
other predictions so let's look at this
architecture a bit more in detail as we
said you have this what they call the
backbone which is a convolutional neural
network and with that you put in some
positional encodings now I already said
the you should look at the these
features right here as just smaller
feature versions of the image but they
still have some image nature then they
are flattened so once they are put in
the transformer encoder because the
transformer is naturally a sequence
processing unit okay
so it takes in just a sequence of
vectors right here and since an image is
not a sequence what you'll do is if you
have your image features and we said we
have a bunch of channels let's say we
have four channels and their height and
width and see you're going to unroll and
flatten that into one sequence so this
is height times width you basically
unroll across these axes right here into
this axis and it's channels I so
basically you have a sequence here of of
C dimensional feature vectors that you
then put into your encoder okay so your
encoder will now transform this sequence
into an equally long sequence yet again
of features and the good thing about a
transformer because why do you use a
transformer the good thing about the
transformer is that in such a sequence
and I've done videos on transformers it
you can basic mainly look at the video
attention is all you need if you want to
under
than this more fully this thing can
basically have a tension so it has
attention layers it can attend from each
position to each position in a one-shot
manner so as it transforms this
representation up the transformer layers
at each step it can basically aggregate
information from everywhere in the
sequence to anywhere else and therefore
it's very it's very powerful if you have
a sequence and you need sort of global
connections across the sequence this is
very good for a language processing
because in a sentence let's look at this
sentence the input images are matched
together all right
applying blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah and then there is
they write the word they and you need
you need to know that they refers to the
input images okay and but you see this
is very very far away in the sentence so
you need a model that makes use of long
range dependencies and they make the
case that in such a task right here you
also need the long range dependencies
because these bounding boxes as you see
right here there can be quite large so
if you have an image you need that this
part here communicates with these and
this and this and this part basically
anywhere in the bounding box and these
bounding boxes can be quite large so the
transformer architecture actually makes
sense here now I want to go a bit later
into why I think it actually makes even
more sense for a bounding box detection
but right now I just want to keep going
through this through this architecture
right here so if my computer here
decides to come back yes we can go on so
what will get out is yet another so in
here we put this thing we put down here
we put into the transformer encoder and
we get an equally sized equally shaped
sequence out of the transformer encoder
you see that this thing here goes as a
side input into this transformer decoder
so the transformer encoder here is just
a bit more of a feature mapping
technically just for the architecture
you could think of just putting this
into here but of course it's gonna go
better with the transformer encoder the
transformer decoder now does something
similar but you see it has the encoder
as a side input this is very much like
this is not like Burt Burt is like a
only encoder transformer whereas this is
much like the original attention is all
you need transformer that has an encoder
and then the decoder as a side input
basically as conditioning information
has the encoder output what does the
decoder do again since it's a
transformer it's going to take a
sequence and output a sequence the
sequence it takes is right here is what
they call object queries and this also
is different from the attention is all
you need papers and they don't do it
autoregressive lee they just do it one
shot what does it mean it means that you
start with a sequence here of four
things and this is these are the this is
this big n and you out you output the
sequence of a sequence of four things
and it's important to see what they're
going to end up so these things are then
directly going through a classifier that
now outputs the so these things here are
these class label bounding box outputs
okay so each of these things is going to
after transformation end up being one of
these bounding boxes either defining an
object or saying that there isn't an
object somewhere okay you see here this
bounding box refers to this bird this
bounding box refers to this bird so each
of these things is going to to be one
bounding box and the what they call
object queries is the question of course
is what do you input here right actually
I want to transform this image
information that comes from the left
here I want to transform
that into the bounding boxes what do I
input here and the answer is you just
input at the start you just input n
random vectors because what's that gonna
give you is basically n outputs you want
and outputs because you want n of these
bounding box classifications so you need
n things and if I input n things into a
transformer it's going to give me n
things as an output and then in each
step I can simply condition on the
information that comes in the images and
it it'll give me right then I can
incorporate that information it's a very
deep learning way of thinking about it
actually that you just need the
information somewhere in there and I
need n things now they go more into
detail into this transformer
architecture help help
in the helpful fashion in the appendix
and will go there quickly so this I
think here makes more sense so the image
features come in here right and you see
this is just a transformer stack an
encoder stack of multi-head self
attention and feed-forward in instants
wise or like token wise feed-forward
network and then that information is
taken and is given as conditioning
information over here now in here as I
said you input these object queries
which at the beginning are just n random
vectors and what you're going to do you
Argos are going to feature and code them
and then you combine it with this image
information so ultimately if you think
of this one of these things one of these
things is going to be a vector right and
then that vector is going to be
transformed and then it will have as it
is transformed it will have the
opportunity to basically look at
features that come from here now the
arrow is in the wrong direction so you
have already taken the image and you've
transformed it into a feature
representation which is also a vector
right you have the features of the image
right here now
as you transform this vector this object
query queue you have the opportunity to
look at the image features right and
that's how do you get the image
information in there so the image
features will come in here transform
that through attention so this is an
attention mechanism on the image and
then what you will output is a bounding
box and a little class label it's really
hard to explain
I would guess you need to understand
really what attention mechanisms are and
of course the crucial part of of course
is what what's this
what do you input at the beginning and
these object queries aren't actually
random as I said they are learned so
what you're going to do is you're going
to learn independent of the input image
you're going to learn n different object
queries and these object queries now
it's very it's very interesting because
these object queries are sort of going
to be different it's like you have
different people that can ask the input
image different questions right and this
they have so there n is 100 but they
show 20 of these object queries that
they learn and so did they have
visualization of all bounding box
predictions on all images so it's it's
sort of like you have n different people
at your disposal and you train these n
different people to kind of ask
different questions of the input image
ok you say this person up here will
always ask irrespective of what the
input image is will always ask sort of
hey input image what's what's on your
bottom left right that's I'm really
interested what's on your bottom left
and sometimes I'm a bit interested in
what's here but I'm mainly interested
what's on the bottom left of the image
whereas this person right here sorry
this person right here
is more interested in what's in the
center that the different colors here is
refer to different sizes of bounding
boxes so this person is also interested
so the person on the top-left is
interested mainly in I think small
bounding boxes that are on the bottom
left and the person here is mostly
interested in what I'm really interested
what's in the center what's large in the
center I want give me large things that
are in the center right and then this
person right here is really interested
on stuff that's on the right side of the
image so you see in order to get
different sort of a difference in
bounding box predictions you train n
different people to ask different
questions of the of the input image and
this asking of questions is exactly what
an attention mechanism is so this person
right here let's let's take this this
person and I'm saying person these are
vectors these are learned object queries
but this person first they will simply
ask the question what's on what's on the
right side and then the image features
right I'm getting poor drawing the image
features it will have an attention
mechanism to this part of the image
features and then it will get back some
signal right and then it will transform
that with its own signal up and then it
will ask maybe again okay now that I
know more because you see that person is
interested in multiple things it's
interested in those things and those
things so at first it will focus on
these things but then it says oh now I'm
now I know more right there is there I
know I see there is actually something
on the right side so in the higher
layers it can then go back and ask the
image more questions by sending these
cue vectors of the attention mechanism
and it will get back the V vectors from
the image features that correspond to
these cue things so up and up the layers
this person can ask more refined
questions about what that particular
person is interested in okay and since
you have the different people here that
ask different questions you basically
learn the people in a way such that
across the data set they all together
they cover every possible image pretty
well again these people what they're
interested in initially is not dependent
on the picture you simply learn this in
a global manner all right this is the
best way I have of describing it you
basically learn n people that are each
one is interested in different things
different classes and different regions
in the image and each one of these
people is going to output their best
guess of what is where based on what
they're interested in so that person
might say I'm you know I'm the person
that's interested kind of in the left
side of things so I am going to output
that there is a bird right here now
these people if this is a transformer
right and everything can attend to
everything they can actually communicate
with each other as they incorporate
information from the image so in each
layer they can do both they can
incorporate information from the image
and they can communicate with each other
and then in the next layer that can do
it again and again and again and thereby
they can sort of they can sort of say
well you already got the left side I
will take the right side you already got
the bird class I will take the elephant
class and so on so you see here how the
the architecture of the transformer
actually is also very conducive to doing
this bounding box prediction in that
these different things can sort of
attend to each other and therefore
communicate with each other all right I
hope that sort of makes sense now before
we get into the experiments I want to
list a third reason of why the
transformer especially the encoders
might actually also make a giant amount
of sense here since you on
the image into height and width and you
have to imagine what does the
transformer do the transformer as we
said here has this notion of a tension
where from any point in the sequence it
can gather information from any other
point in the sequence and this that's
usually one of the downsides of the
Transformers is done via a quadratic
attention mechanism so if I just list
one feature channel go over here if I
just list one feature Channel right here
this is height times width of the image
right this is this is the entire image
unrolled in one vector height times
width and here I unroll it again height
times width then this this matrix that I
can build right here which is called the
attention matrix right here it will tell
me which parts of the sequence attends
to which other parts okay so if you have
an image that has the let's say the
number three and you really want to
figure out whether or not this is a
three then the bow up here must
communicate with the bow down here right
they need to share information you say
oh there's a bow here there's a bow here
and there is a spiky thing here that
must be a three so you want something
this is rather at the beginning of the
sequence you want this to attend first
of all it will attend itself so you get
fairly high values along the diagonal
maybe 1010 1011 1112 and I saw this all
eg skated a hundred million nine nine
but it also like this this part here at
the beginning of the sequence let's say
it's here because this is unrolled right
needs to attend to the end so this needs
to attend to the end which we will put
an 11 here and the other way around
doesn't always need to be symmetrical by
the way
okay but in any case this is going to be
a H times W squared matrix because
everything can attend to everything and
that's the attention mechanism
why do I think this is so good for
bounding boxes because let's let's
imagine you actually have a matrix that
is like this okay height times width
times height times width every single
point in here actually defines a
bounding box because this point this
point right here in this dimension
corresponds to one location in the image
and on this axis it corresponds to
another location now in the attention
matrix simply means these two points
need to communicate but if you have two
pixels you actually have defined a
bounding box right here right you you
were actually you're defining a bounding
box and the fact that this is happening
in the exact same matrices could mean
that the Transformers are uniquely well
the Transformers across sequences of
these height times with unrolled images
are uniquely well conducive to these
bounding box prediction tasks I'm
actually a bit astounded because when I
first just read the title this
immediately popped to my mind I'm like
oh yes of course and they're going to
predict the bounding boxes by simply
training so what you would do what I
thought this was gonna be as out you
output an actual matrix like this and
then you simply each point you can you
can simply classify right so you can
classify here whether whether or not
like at in this direction there is a
bird right and then if you have two
points like this for example you and you
also classify whether in this direction
there is a bird right and this naturally
defines a bounding box or you could like
take this matrix and actually just
classify individual points in this
matrix to be the bounding boxes because
they already define bounding boxes so I
just I think these these quadratic
things are are uniquely I mean someone
must have thought of this or if not like
the YouTube channel it would be funny
first paper ever to actually have to
cite the YouTube channel but again yeah
so
transformers seem to be a good idea for
these kinds of things so how do they do
of course they do well they are on par
where with these other much much much
more complex architectures these faster
our CNN models they are apparently much
more complex but they are on par with
this they do however train forever
I think they train for like six days on
eight GPUs is not that much if you
compare to like language models on
hundreds of TP use but still okay I
don't want to go into the numbers of
experiments but what is really cool is
that they can now visualize this sort of
attention and you can see right here
that if they look at a particular point
in the image and visualize the attention
it will actually attend to the instance
itself so it will like these are usually
the problems for these detection
algorithms when things overlap and are
partially occluded but you can see right
here that the attention is on the part
of the image that makes the instance in
the back and the attention here is on
the part of this and it doesn't sort of
overlap into the others so that is one
thing that's pretty impressive about
these architectures the other thing they
show is for example it can generalize to
many many instances so here it has never
seen 24 giraffes in one image but yet it
can absolutely do that and giraffe
giraffe to rupture after of and the one
of the coolest images I find are these
here where you can see right here again
attention visualisation and you see that
even within the bounding box of the
front elephant here you see that the
attention on this foot of the back
elephant is is is assigned to this blue
bounding box so this is the blue
basically the blue bounding box person
that is attending to that back foot that
means they
they these things really sort of
understand or they learn these things
like occlusion and you know just hard I
have a hard time describing it but you
can see it visually here right like how
it clearly learns that these are two
instances that are sort of occluding
each other but this this this instance
can actually appear within the bounding
box of the other instance and the same
goes for the zebra here that are
partially occluding each other and you
can see that the attention is correctly
like even here this back foot of this
zebra is correctly labeled so all in all
that is pretty cool and they take it a
step further and they say well with this
architecture we can actually pretty
easily do pixel wise classification so
this is this cocoa stuff and things data
set where I don't know which one is the
stuff and which one is the things I
think things is the objects and stuff is
like sky and mountains and so on and so
this is a classification task where you
actually have to label every single
pixel so what they do is they simply
input this through their detector and
they detect the instances they take the
attention maps of the instances and then
they scale it up this right here is just
a CNN sort of in Reverse that scales up
the image because they have scaled it
down as we said they scale it up again
and then they scan simply classify each
pixel where each of these you remember
we had these different people here that
it that cared about different things in
the image each of these people will
classify their respective pixels the
pixels they feel responsible for and
then you simply merge all of these
people's predictions together into this
prediction and again this gives pretty
pretty impressive results I am I mean
this is this is fun this looks like it
sort of works I haven't
they do quantitative analysis of course
but I'm just impressed by the examples
right here alright that was sort of it I
really enjoyed reading this papers the
simplicity is pretty cool they do have
not only do they have code in the paper
to show how ridiculously easy it is to
get this to run this is all you need in
pi torch but they do actually have code
and as I understand they also have pre
trained models so they have this model
Zoo right here where they give you the
pre trained models so you can play with
it and you can even load it from torch
hub yourself and you can train it
yourself they have a collab all is there
all right
again if you enjoy this video consider
leaving a like subscribing and I'll see
you next time bye bye